it's just so funny to think about how
vacation seems like a million years ago
literally we're just thinking like how
not motivated I am for the showman
aspect of this you know like not only I
believe back in the grind I'm like so
deeply in it that like it was funny
somebody left the comment I ended the
episode two episodes ago I guess with
like you know just a grimy yeah and the
guy did you see his comment he was like
what do you mean grimy and hustle and
execution all this guy does is walk
around and shake people's hands have a
good day let me just I'll back up where
I can look the punchline is that you
know if you weren't the first mover on
the platform itself you can still be a
first mover by being the first mover in
a new feature like live video
capabilities or in this example filters
for some our Instagram stories there's
always gonna be new feature builds on
these platforms that allow a new
opportunity to be the first mover
tactically instead of within that
platform so it's kind of think of it
like real estate where you might have
not been first in California but you
could be first at in Malibu and so it's
like neighborhood you know buying up
neighborhoods instead of buying up New
York City the person that here's a great
example there's a lot of people that
make money in Manhattan and New York but
you know you could have been the person
that made money in Dumbo you know so the
bottom line is this is continuing to
happen every person reading this article
still can deploy this exact strategy
which is why I'm featuring it to all of
you if you are targeting 13 to 35 year
olds
yep I make decisions that are predicated
on whether this person's telling the
truth or not
is relevant on making this decision
because impacts I think when you
actually have less expectation of others
there's an incredible life to be lived
it's stunning how little I expect from
others I take it as a pleasant surprise
and as a positive when one does the
normal based thing that humans should do
it I think that most people start with
way too high expectations and then
people disappoint them I go the reverse
unless it makes it easy for me so I've
never been really ever crippled by the
notion of this person telling me the
truth you want the real information to
me I'm a post-game guy if they're not
telling the truth I'll deal with that
later I'm not worried about at that
moment dwelling overthinking slows you
down and that becomes a problem that to
me is the KPI speed channel I think it's
actually pretty easy to judge a speaker
you know for example I think I have
substance but I have a lot of
motivational tendencies above it I also
think it's important to see what they've
done for example you know if they're
actually she or he is actually building
businesses and they happen to be
motivational then you know then there's
something happening in the day job right
if they're just coming out the gate and
saying I'm the most motivational guru
and only sell books and only do seminars
then then that's what they do and I've
struggled with the notion of you know
this more
I've got motivational tendencies but
I've been said proud of actually
building two very large tangible
businesses being an actual investor
Nicky stuff happens so I think I think
it's just a dissect the words and more
totally lives are only a very small part
of the equation when any of those words
just dancing da prata what's up man
baby's good really good to see you again
oh yeah are you because I don't want to
count my [ __ ] chickens shot like
honestly like I've done well I've made
it I'm good I want to keep winning but I
don't know like maybe maybe I fall off
like I want to stay hungry I'm not ready
to you know do rocks okay this cabbie he
knew who you were I'm like no no he just
saw that you were with you know with a
camera with me like I am big enough ego
in me already
I gotta need to make sure that I've big
enough humility to go with it cuz that's
how you get somewhere second you think
you've won
somebody's gonna create it it's so real
I'm scared that like especially as for
as much [ __ ] as I talk like I'm gonna
buy the Jets like I'm [ __ ] suffocating
myself put myself in the corner of never
being able to let off so yeah so back to
your question back to your question
everybody's got the reality like
everybody's got the reality you know my
answer to this is I don't so I'm gonna
give an answer that is valuable to
everybody listening and I'm gonna give
the real answer which is not as valuable
the real answer is I don't [ __ ] know
the real answer is that guy needs to
know himself
like some people learns like if that guy
knows himself and he knows he's a good
student and he doesn't have the ambition
to buy the New York Jets and his
ambition is to make 81 thousand dollars
a year beyond three softball teams have
good work-life balance you know get us
one or two vacations a year or not have
a whole lot of stress well in school and
go get go into the machine if he's like
me and could have breathe in school
[ __ ] hated school wanted it
action [ __ ] huge [ __ ] sick computers
it his brain because he needs action
well then he needs to go and just do if
he's looking for a lotto ticket make a
business plan business plans the whack
one on most business plans the [ __ ]
that's the the marriage of the two above
that means nothing that's half pregnant
business plans a [ __ ] in today's
world because you don't believe that
that's right who the [ __ ] are you pitch
it that old white shoe doesn't matter
anymore like like like like what
PowerPoint do you need to get you know
like so that's just that's you know what
that's called that's that's called
somebody being in a fantasy in her own
mind and that's the person that says to
their homies I've got a business plan
that's just a proxy for like that's
peacocking [ __ ] there's no business
plan go do this [ __ ] I've fought against
that my whole life because I think it's
the cheesy thing like I don't wanna be a
motivational speaker weird conference
halls like that's weird but if I can be
a businessman that has motivational DNA
well that's interesting because then
what what the difference is is I think a
lot of motivational speakers just keep
wanting to go to the bottom and keep
having like they almost like I basically
want nobody to watch me I want people to
consume my [ __ ] get a couple ideas get
pumped and go do love you guys know
something here you know do something I
love you guys thank you and you sure
we showed the outdoor watch Cheers you
shoot the uppercut new Notification
Center which is which is like a major
step forward and it leads to the watch
and this is like all the alerts you can
get on the watch like I guess we're
technically into Thursday stop good day
for resi good day for a bunch of
meetings just put up a sock on my boy a
shark like that it's gonna see him she's
good to put in another day's work
good solid days of work the work it
Trump's everything
it's the one non-debatable in debate
talent you could debate luck it's gonna
make circumstance cants a pain if
somebody's putting in the work not
subjective [ __ ] use that are
put in the 15 16 18 hours of work that
gives you the best position to succeed
in what you're trying to achieve or you
don't so you can have opinions but you
can't
didn't meet the [ __ ] data I think
about putting in the work in the same
way I think about having the best
product right like like the best product
just wins like there's there's so much
that is debatable things that you can't
put your fingers on but the market is
the market is the market the market
decides the best products and you the
market watch this and understand like
look you can come up with all your
theories all you want putting in the
[ __ ] work I'm putting in ooh
[Music]